here with reaction is the ranking member
of the house judiciary committee jim
jordan along with
wisconsin senator ron johnson uh good to
see you both
uh let me go to your side in the house
first jim jordan and let's
let's get these new developments that we
found out today are pretty revealing
they're acknowledging everything people
like you and i were saying
for three years about what happened yep
no widespread abuse on it and we need to
put it all in context 10 years ago the
irs was targeting people who
conservatives people who view your show
five years ago as you pointed out
the fbi abused the fisa process to
target president trump's campaign to spy
on president trump
and his campaign and now we find out
there is widespread abuse in the fisa
process
no change remember it was just a year
and a half ago that mr horowitz reported
that 29 randomly selected applications
he looked at there were problems with
all of them
four of them they couldn't even find the
underlying documentation which has
required the woods file they couldn't
even find that before the 29
so it looks like nothing has changed and
when you couple all that with what they
did to senator johnson
what they did to the president's lawyer
last week when they raided his apartment
this is frightening and it's you know
when confidential information is leaked
senator johnson
uh doesn't that put everybody at risk
sources
methods operatives in the field
i believe so you know i referred to the
obama administration as a lawless
administration this is in the face of
president obama declaring there wasn't
some tilla
a proof of any scandal in his in his
administration uh completely false
but it's just continuation of this when
you see the unequal
administration application of justice in
the law
that should frighten every american and
we're continuing to see it
my latest episode had to do with a
briefing
i received apparently they were they
were looking at giving judy giuliani a
similar briefing
i i suspect for the time is a complete
setup now i'm quite certain based on how
this was leaked to the washington post
and other publications it was a complete
setup
to again paint me as some kind of dupe
of russia nothing could be further from
the truth
and try and destroy me politically but
that that is what the left does and
that's how
the press uh cooperates with democrat
parties which they are basically the
communication shop
of let me go back to jim jordan okay
we now know that the dirty clinton
bought and paid for russia
misinformation dossier we know a lot
about it
we know that christopher steele himself
didn't stand behind
it and that was before january of 2017
we know that the main source of the
dossier said no this was all bar
talk in other words it was lies
unverifiable lies
last time i checked i've been told i
haven't seen one but it says at the top
of a fisa application
verified but now knowing all we know
it's unverified and even
comey and yates and rod rosenstein all
three of them have said well knowing
what we know now we wouldn't have signed
off on it
well if it was verified why did
unverifiable
why did you sign off on it and when you
found out the truth
as a matter of law you're supposed to go
back and tell the court
we gave you information we believe to be
true that turns out
not to be true but they just continue to
apply every three months for another
warrant now
jim jordan tell me if i'm wrong i'll
hand it to you
if i lied to a fisa court where would i
be right now
no you'd be in jail and and again sean
you're exactly right never forget
we deposed jim comey after he had been
fired and he told us in that deposition
after 10 months of investigating
president trump this whole fake russia
trump collusion effort this whole fake
or ordeal
after 10 months they still didn't have
anything but he didn't tell us that in
fact
he pushed for the special counsel and we
had to live through another two years of
that
and now we find out the abuse is still
going on and i always remind people
remember
this is spying on americans what they're
doing here it's the foreign intelligence
surveillance act it's the foreign
intelligence surveillance court
what are they doing spying on americans
that is the thing that troubles us so
much
and this is why we should have hearings
but jerry nadler has yet to have
a full committee hearing this entire
congress i bet he's probably not going
to do the first one
on this issue let me move to a different
issue with you
senator johnson because you and your
colleague senator charles grassley
you put together a report on hunter
biden
last night on this program we showed joe
biden leveraging a billion taxpayer
dollars
telling ukraine at the time he's vice
president in charge of ukrainian policy
that either you fire a prosecutor or
you're not getting the billion you got
six hours bragging that he got him to
fire the prosecutor
the prosecutor was exp was looking into
and investigating
barista oil and gas company
and zero experienced hunter his 50 year
old son
admits on gma he had no experience in
oil gas energy
or ukraine and then your report went
further
about a kazakhstan oligarch and monies
that were transferred to his company
the first lady of moscow three and a
half million dollars
a hundred thousand dollar shopping spree
with a chinese national
and then of course the 1.5 billion
dollar deal with the bank of china with
seemingly no experience in that field
either so
my question is how come nobody ever got
to the bottom of that because i suspect
senator johnson if i did that too
i think i'd be in jail with jim jordan
bro but sean you're a conservative
you're republicans so yeah
they're going to go after you with
everything they've got hunter biden joe
biden they're democrats
and so they they get to skate home free
john kerry
lies about the fact that he apparently
knew nothing about
the fact that uh hunter biden got that
uh a board position
and barisma now he's lying about uh not
apparently
uh revealing classified information to
uh the iranian foreign minister
so again democrats skate because the
media is part and parcel of the democrat
party they will cover for them
they will explain problems away but it's
again in in
our unfortunately our fbi our department
of justice
is equally biased and they are not
administering justice equally in this
country and that should concern every
american
last time senator you were on this
program uh
i i kind of was probing you're you'd be
up for re-election in 2022
are you planning to run because
democrats have already
put a target political target be clear
uh on you and your seat they want
they want to defeat you more than any
other republican
in this current cycle going into 2022.
are you planning on running
because i think a lot of the country
would like to support you and i think
the people of wisconsin will also
just like they'd support jim jordan if
he had the courage to step up and run
for senate
well the attacks certainly fire me up
i'm going to do everything i can to make
sure that this u.s senate see
stays in the hands of republican i could
do a full instagram on you and
say if you want to donate ron johnson
for senate dot com
but i won't go that far well i guess i
did but then no
sean i'm gonna do everything i can to
make sure that this thing this seat
stays in the hands republican
uh and that will certainly be part of my
decision factor
all right we'll look forward to that
decision what do you think about what do
you think about senator jordan do you
like that name senator johnson
i like it sounds good rolls off the
tongue really well
it does but congressman jordan does for
senator john house as well
uh all right we'll just keep the
pressure on he's a wrestler he's tough
to take down and pin down all right
thank you both senator and congressman
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else